i've got some
disturbing news
if you're driving pull over if you're
standing up you're probably going to
want to sit down
the singer lizzo
known for very publicly and very
emphatically being corpulent
and proud of
her corpulence
lizzo wants to
strip
for playboy
[Music]
i'm speechless
i she was asked by tmz about playboy she
said i love playboy i want to strip for
playboy and i don't i'm really
torn here i think a lot of conservatives
are in a tough spot because it's very
rude to say anything mean certainly
about a woman's appearance but but
really about anybody's appearance and i
don't want to do that
i don't i don't i want to be polite i
want to be nice i i no one but the
culture is kind of forcing us to now
because the
leftist culture is dead set on
destroying all traditional standards
standards of truth standards of beauty
standards of virtue and goodness and
they're
they're installing a kind of
anti-standard in its place
right we're told
not only are you not allowed to say that
men are not women but you have to say
that certain men are women
not only are you not allowed to say that
certain art let's say the sistine chapel
is more beautiful than other art uh say
the the urinal by the modern artist
in those stupid modern art museums not
only are you not allowed to say that you
have to say that the modern art is
beautiful
you ha and so we have just all the
billboards now all of the advertising
used to have smoke and hot women
advertising all of the clothing and new
products now it's actively trying to
model things on
not the most beautiful stuff
nobody wants lizzo to
model in playboy one because you know
it's probably not
the most edifying enobling thing in the
world it probably wouldn't be great for
lizzo
and but people
people don't want to see that and it's
not
that's not bigoted not to want to see
lizzo naked it's not it's not it doesn't
make you a bad person that you don't
fight if you don't find lizzo attractive
or physically attractive okay there is
this
there's this amazing
misunderstanding of what really matters
in life going on here because
on the one hand you've got
the previously in our society maybe 20
30 years ago you had an obsession with
perfecting the body airbrushing all
these sorts of eating disorders all
these ways to to plastic surgery to make
yourself look perfect you have to
perfect the body now we've moved in
completely the opposite direction people
want to distort their bodies through
mutilations through uh ver
sort of insane piercings and tattooing
and and uh eating disorders in the other
direction so we're we're we're focused
on basically the same thing two sides at
the same point we've got to perfect the
body in all ways when was the last time
we talked about perfecting the soul when
was the last time we talked about
ennobling ourselves and practicing
virtue and that that's completely gone
from the conversation we're stuck in
this crazy materialist trap
i'm glad you like that clip you know
what you can do to get more clips you
can ring the bell subscribe to the
michael knowles show if you're not
getting notifications for whatever
reason youtube head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]